nous sommes avec Abdel Ali Mamoun merci
d'être avec nous monsieur l'imam merci
d'être là alors vous avez fait
énormément parler de vous après cette
interview de ce matin sur BFM d' sur
c'est sur BFM ou avec àuline de Malherbe
et c'est vrai que il y a il y a des
extraits qui ont retenu l'attention des
des téléspectateurs on parlait il y a un
instant avec vous il y avait plusieurs
questions don celle de Gilles oui moi il
y a quelque chose qui m'étonne dans
votre discours c'est l'ambigué que vous
maintenez au sujet
acte terroriste du Hamas ou alors crime
de guerre commis par la branche armée du
Hamas je pense que pour que les
musulmans soient audibles et puisse
réclamer aujourd'hui un cesser le feu un
arrêt du massacre sur Gaza il faut
reconnaître qu'il y a eu une action
terroriste le 7 octobre du Hamas sinon
je trouve que ça fragilise la demande de
cesser le feu mais visiblement vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça écoutez si
s'il faut vraiment qu'on débat sur la
sémantique entre crime de guerre
attendez laissez-moi terminer la
sémantique de crime de guerre qui est
l'expression du droit international qui
permettrait de poursuivre les les
auteurs de ces atrocités alors que le
chef d'inculpation de terrorisme ils en
sortirai totalement disculpé puisqu'il
n'existe pas et donc ça c'est la
première raison pourquoi il faut UER TER
reconnaître que le Hamas est un groupe
terroriste cette même phrase vous la
présentez sous un aspect vous oubliez de
dire l'autre aspect attendez j'y viens
j'y viens bah attendez j'y
viensé crime contre l'humanité crime de
guerre effectivement tout à fait mais
c'est pas la même chose que terroriste
éc une organisation terroriste c'est une
organisation qui a été euh qui a été
créé de manière anarchique et qui n'est
qui n'a aucune reconnaissance
internationale aujourd'hui Hamas je
parle de de ce parti politique qui a été
élu en 2006 a été reconnu à l'époque
comme étant le parti qui a gagné les
élections dans la bande de Gaza et qui
après euh s'est radicalisé s'est
transformé en une organisation qui a tué
pas été élu pour affamer sa population
il a pas été élu pour placer des caches
d'armes sous les hôpitaux il a pas été
élu
son la prison à ciel ouvert que
aujourd'hui vit la population de gaz je
POS la question autrement vous pensez
que le Hamas défend bien la population
au contraire elle a desservi totalement
les intérêts bien sûr qu'il faut la
condamner et bien quand je mois
j'entends et je vois des atrocités qu'on
dit être émanant d'une organisation
islamique donc qui se réfère au Coran et
qui interdit catégoriquement que l'on
tue des enfants que l'on décapite des
femmes que l'on s'en prend à des civils
je parle de texes religieux musulmans
qui l'interdisent et que il se
revendique au nom de l'islam comme étant
que tous ces actes ont été perpétrés au
nom de d'une d'une étiquette islamique
et bien je trouve ça ignoble de leur
part ils trahissent nos valeurs ils
trahissent notre religion en perpétrant
ces actes-là qui sont horriblees et qui
sont des actes de barbarie qui doit être
condamné et pour cela je euh je je veux
citer les noms euh comme il se doit euh
pour qu'il puisse être poursuivi et ce
ce ce ce nom-là c'est crime contre
l'humanité c'est barbarie acte de
barbarie euh viol parce qu''il y a eu
même des femmes qui ont été violées
comment toi tu es un musulman tu violes
tu te dis mouvement de résistance
islamique donc tu te revendiques de de
l'islam et et tu violes des femmes et tu
capites des enfants et tu tues des
enfants et et et tu tu mutiles des corps
alors que tout cela était clairement
interdit dans le Coran c'est c'est tout
à fait condamnable je le je le condamne
sans aucune réserve maintenant dans un
second temps ce que perpétue aujourd'hui
[Musique]
gazaal en voulant appréhender ces
criminels tirer dans la foule parce que
moi j'ai jamais entendu parler qu'il
était permis à un policier pour pouvoir
appréhender un criminel dans la foule de
tirer dans la foule on tire pas dans la
foule on ne fait pas on ne dit pas on
justifie pas des des des dommages
collatéraux et qui sont très conséquents
parce qu'on parle depuis 11000 morts
avec plus de 5000 enfants qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait Paron est dans une
pleine guerre informationnelle et
personne ne peut attester des chiffres
et vous le savez très bien tout ce qui
sort de la bande de Gaza est contrôlé
par le Hamas donc attention aux chiffres
vous avez peut-être raison mais
peut-être que vous allez tort aussi
atttion écoutez moi je dis que pour
régler ça et pour être dans la
transparence il faudrait que il faudrait
que l'armée gouvernement de netanah
autor
que il y a des
ONG proposer des moments des moments des
trêv d'abord pour laisser rentrer les
organisations humanitaires et les ONG
qui puissent compter et qui puissent
voir et faire le constat de ce qui se
passe de manière à faire des enquêtes
neutres et indépendantes pour que
finalement nous ayons comme de d'un côté
comme de l'autre une une une réalité qui
n'est pas on va dire biaisée ni déformé
par la guerre puisque la première
victime de la guerre c'est la vérité il
faudrait aussi libérer les otages
d'ailleurs ah oui bien sûr oui bien sûr
que je suis le premier à vouloir leur
libération écoutez un imam écoutez un
imam il n'est pas là pour faire de la
politique ni française ni international
un imam il est là pour promouvoir la pai
on n'est pas là pour condamner on est là
pour les personnes on condamne les ACT
compes pour tous les musulmans de France
c'est très important vous étiez pas bien
ce matin ou quoi on a l'impression que
c'est pas le même oui oui peut-être que
je venais de me réveiller vousimz pas
vous aimez pas Pauline de malerme il y a
quoi elle m'a elle m'a retranché dans
vers des propos peut-être que j'étais
mal droit je me suis laissé prendre au
piège par par par AP Pauline qui m'a
pris me rabachant constamment le fait
que je doutais que je voulais des
preuves et cetera faites plus
d'émissions le matin ouais ouais
peut-être vous invite à Télé Matin n'y
allz pas je vous cache pas que là je
suis particulrement excédué fatigué et
j'essaie de d'être de rester nous qu
même ah oui oui bien sûr une ambiance
sympa moi il y a un passage je sais pas
si on l' qui m'a choqué c'est votre
façon d'expliquer et même de justifier
pratique alors je veux pas vous accuser
à vous allez peut-être nous l'expliquer
ce que l'action du du du 7 octobre je
sais pas si on a cet extrait mais il m'a
choqué notamment un mot je on est
aujourd'hui le jour où les les images de
cette barbarie quand même sont sont
montré à des des gens de l'Assemblée
nationale alors vous l'avez parce que je
peux le répéter mais ça sera peut-être
plus fort de ces gens-là qui ont été
choisis par la population de de Gaza
pour défendre leur intérêt on pensait on
jugeait bêtement certes et de criminelle
je condamne fermement leur leur leur
exaction qu'ils ont commis le 7 octobre
mais ils ont dit que pour pouvoir
réveiller l'opinion internationale face
au sort que subit Gaza depuis des
décennies il fallait aller tuer voilà
c'est c'est leur leur réflexion ils se
sont dit voilà c'est le seul moyen pour
réveiller les consciences
internationales et ils ont réussi faut
le dire ils ont réussi c'est pas le bon
ex moi c'est c'est
l'ex le mot bêtement déjà ils ont
bêtement ils ont été faire des actes de
barbarie pour éveiller les les
consciences pour alerter le monde mais
vous enfin c'est pas une alors peut-être
expliquez-vous est-ce que c'est pas une
justification de cette barbarie du 7
octobre d'abord d'abord je je dis que ce
n'est pas moi qui réfléchit de cette
manière-là je dis que c'est eux qui ont
réfléchi cette manière-là mais j'étais
dans une démarche de vouloir non pas
justifier mais expliquer pourquoi ils
ont fait ça et il est important pour
voir chercher des portes et des voix de
la paix d'essayer de comprendre les
motivations qui ont fait que ces gens-là
ont même un juge va reprendre les
arguments d'un criminel au moment dire
pourquoi vous avez fait ça oui c'est un
crime passionnel parce que ma femme m'a
trompé même voilà vous ce que je veux
dire le le juge il est là pour reprendre
les termes euh qui vont essayer
d'expliquer de justifier du moins par
eux leur acte criminel mais moi je ne
suis pas là pour cautionner bien sûr que
non au contraire je les condamne
fermement il n'y a aucun justificatif
qui permettra mais par contre par contre
il y a quand même une chose à préciser
c'est que que on le sait Gaza Gaza est
une est une petite un petit territoire
où il y a la plus grande densité de
population au monde et qui est sous
perfusion depuis plusieurs décennies pas
plusieurs années plusieurs décennies et
qui est aujourd'hui une population qui a
qui qui vit sur les aides
internationales parce qu'ils ne peuvent
ni commercer ni voyager ni ils sont dans
une prison c'est les gens qu'ils ont
dedans n'ont pas le droit de sortir et
les checkpoint partout et et et et
forcément j'essaie moi en même temps qui
est censé distribuer redistribuer
l'argent de au sein de la population de
Gaza quel argent et l'argent qu'il
reçoivent notamment mais d'abord
pourquoi on devrait pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi la population devrait passer
par Gaza pourquoi on nouvre pas les
frontières de ces populations de ces
civiles qui veulent simplement vivre et
qui sont enfermés mais qui qui enferme
la population de Gaza qui c'est c'est
hamasp répondez-moi est-ce que c'est
Hamas qui ferme la frontière qui tient
les frontières de la Palestine il y a
l'Égypte c'est ça il y a l'Égypte et il
y a aussi c'est comme un accord avec
Israël qui ne doit pas l'ouvrir que
seulement avec la permission d'Israël on
est d'accord et que du côté israélien du
côté palestinien il y a aussi un
checkpoint israélien et on laisse pas
passer ni les nourritures que seulement
selon bon vouloir de de de l'état de
l'État d'Israël et les gens vivent sous
perfusion ils vivent au comptegoutte
alors une heure une heure de 1 heure
d'électricité par jour l'eau je vous en
parle même pas tout ça vous avez raison
tout ça vous avez raison ils vivent dans
des conditions et après on s'étonne on
s'étonne que ça éclate bien depuis une
quinaine ça explique à les reennes ils
sont responsables politiquement ils sont
censés pouvoir redistribuer l'argent
d'accord qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que fait on
la population reste en otage face à ça
CRV elles doivent crever parlez de
responsabilité la respons de sont une
responsabilité partagé voilà mais c'est
ce que je dis depuis le début je je
demande à tous de reconnaître la
responsabilité à la fois de Hamas qui a
commis des TR des des crimes odieux à
l'égard du peuple palestinien et à
l'égard du peuple Isra à la Gard de son
propre peuple de son c'est ce que je
viens dire c'est ce que je viens dire en
premier à l'gard du peuple de Palestine
de Gaza et à la fois les actes odieux
qu'ils ont commis commis le 7 octobre
mais la mais en contrepartie la
transgression de l'armée israélienne
quand elle tire et bombarde la
population et qu'elle dis c'est pas
grave ce sont des animaux on entend même
des généraux comparer les habitants pas
Hamas les habitants de Gaza comme étant
des animaux qui toute façon ne mérite
pas de vivre je trouve ça tout
simplement inadmissible et et j'aimerais
bien que vous aussi
am c'est le cas oui vous avez raison moi
j'ai une question sur vous euh il y a
une telle transformation euh entre le
discours de ce matin et celui-là euh
vous avez pris des coups euh c'està-dire
que tout le monde s'est désolidarisé de
vous le le ministère de l'Intérieur
voilà la Mosquée de Paris le ministère
de l'Intérieur est-ce que du coup vous
vous êtes dit j'ai fait une énorme
connerie je réfléchis et je fais un
monde honorable mais à coule pas parce
que le discours là est on est d'accord
ou pas mais c'est mesuré ce matin ça
l'était pas du tout qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui écoutez je reconnais
ma maladresse je reconnais mais mais
c'est sont des propos qui ont été mal
compris et qui ont été en plus euh
gonflés en voulant me faire dire ce que
je ne disais pas et je j'aurais quand
vous quand vous me regardez vous
m'entendez bien effectivement condamné
et et fermement il y a parce qu'il y a
pas eu que ces extraits que l'on voitim
vous niz les chiffres c'est ça qui est
non je n'ai pas nié les chiffres j'ai
demandé des détails parce que j'étais
euh euh euh stupéfait d'entendre ce
chiffre là marche dimanche c'est que les
chiffres étaient énormes lesi pas je
vous dire même que la communauté musule
même la communauté musulmane ignorait
ces chiffres moi si moi l'imam je les
connais pas la plupart des musulmans la
connaissent pas aussi qui vous
atcnaissance vous a été reproché
monsieuram aussi c'est de trouver des
explications au drame du 7 octobre c'est
ça aussi qui a été voilà fortement qui a
fortement des plus c'estàdz dit voilà
vous avez trouvé exp
j non non non non il n'a jamais été
question de justifier quoi que ce soit
je je répète et je le redis main de fois
je condamne fermement sans réserve ces
atrocités ces actes de barbarie qui ont
été perpétrés par Hames qui se
revendique comme une organisation
musulmane alors qu'elle était en totale
contradiction à la fois avec le droit
international et le droit musulman et
les règles de l'islam qui interdisent
justement de s'en prendre à des civils à
des enfants ou à des femmes ou à des
personnes fragiles et et et cetera donc
nous l'avons je le répète combien fois
faut je le
dis des causes a des
causes vous avez quelques minutes que vu
la situation au bout d'un moment c'est
pas anormal c'est normal ça
exploseendend dis fallait
Falla ah bon justificative ou
explication non non je je ne justifie
pas je ne je je je ne cautionne pas je
condamne fermement mais il faut donner
des explications pour trouver des voies
de paix il faut expliquer les choses
parce que pour que il y ait la paix en
Israël il faut que Israël aussi
fasse amende honorable et dire que voilà
enfin nous sommes prêts à négocier la
paix et nous sommes ouverts comme l'a
proposé la France depuis des qui est la
position officielle depuis des années
d'abord un cesser le feu et ensuite on
réoubl nugation pour avoir deux États
qui d'un côté les Palestiniens
protégeraient l'Israël de ses
populations puisque elle elle pourrait
agir et avoir les moyens alors que Hamas
c'est exactement le contraire qu'elle
veut elle veut monter la population de
Gaza contre Israël alors que un État
palestinien dirait bah non maintenant
vous êtes chez vous vous avez votre pays
vous pouvez aller voyager en Israël il y
a aucun problème comme le ferait un
israélien qui viendrait en paix en toute
sécurité sur le teritoire palestinien
mais aujourd'hui Israël n' veut pas ne
veut pas de cette solution et il est là
le problème je disais que il y a ça ne
justifie pas ça explique pourquoi
aujourd'hui et
bien aussi expliquer le rôle des pays
arabes dans la région on do on do on
doit faire une petite pause là merci on
va se retrouver dans un instant il y a
questions de mundir Raymon Géraldine
Gill encore avec plaisir non mais
c'était pas
prévu